what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and today i will be
jumping right back into the latest
events in the mha story including toru
hagakura's face reveal after seven years
class 1a's reaction to the shocking ua
trader reveal and all for one's secret
plan that goes way beyond just one
traitor so let's get into it if you
enjoy our boku no hero videos and you
want us to make more in the future just
leave a quick like and comment it only
takes like a second but it helps a lot
with the youtube algorithm and if you're
new to the channel or maybe you watch
our videos but you just haven't taken
the time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video that you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications all you
have to do is click that subscribe
button click the little bell and select
the option that says all you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror finally this video will
contain boku no hero manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned we start things off from the
perspective of the villains basically we
are picking right up from the final line
of chapter 335 when all for once said
that he has many friends to dobby in
fact he apparently has friends to spare
dobby knows that offer one is referring
to the ua trader and he asks what will
happen if the trader ever gets exposed
wouldn't that throw a massive hurdle
into all for one's plans but olferon
isn't worried at all and he's just like
sitting back in his chair and smiling
even as shigaraki continues to ride in
pain on the ground all for one clearly
isn't a very empathetic or emotional
person just a pure unadulterated evil
mastermind who wants to take over the
world and in the spirit of that all for
one compares the traitor to a cheap
lighter clearly implying that he has
many other tricks up his sleeve and if
the ua trader fails it will be a little
disappointing but then he will just move
on to the next plan note that horikoshi
is really going out of his way to tell
us that all for one has multiple plans
in play and that even with aoyama being
exposed as the traitor the threat of all
for one infiltrating the ua is still
very real we have to remember that a
whole bunch of civilians were allowed to
enter the ua grounds because the ua
became a shelter so who's to say that
some of these civilians are not really
civilians but rather people that are
employed by all for one in fact i am
willing to bet that some of these
civilians were plants sent by the
villains but these guys obviously won't
have the same level of access to with
the other class 1a students as a class
1a student would the chapter then jumps
back to the forest where toru and deku
have come face to face with aoyama and
his parents aoyama's parents tell their
son to run and it's clear that they
really do care about him yuga remembers
that when he was a child he had every
luxury and convenience imaginable
because both of his parents came from
wealthy families but at the same time
both of his parents were very concerned
about the fact that he was born
quirkless just as i speculated in a
previous video it seems that being part
of the wealthy elite made alyama's
parents even more concerned about yuga's
quirklessness than he was the wealthy
elites tend to care more about fitting
in with their social circle than regular
people do so the fact that their son was
quirkless was causing the aoyama's
potential social problems at the same
time though you guys convinced that his
parents just wanted him to be happy and
so when they came across a rumor that
someone out there could give their son a
quirk they jumped on the opportunity
even though that quirk ended up being
incompatible with yuga's body his
parents did their best to support him
and eventually they found that special
belt for him a belt that allowed him to
finally control his quirk i just want to
mention that even though aoyama seems
convinced that his parents only had the
best of intentions we still didn't get a
full explanation about how they managed
to get in touch with all for one we were
just told that they heard rumors and
then bam yuga has a quirk to me the fact
that they knew how to get in touch with
all for one and make a deal with him is
still kind of suspicious after all all
for one would have been the most wanted
criminal in the country at that time so
if aoyama's parents could get in touch
with him and they had no prior
connection to him you would think that
the heroes and the police would have
been able to stage a sting operation
using the same mo in order to find him
but to place any further suspicion on
ayama's parents we would need to get
more information so let's move on after
getting his quirk and then receiving the
special belt that allowed him to control
it aoyama was actually happy and he was
excited to pursue his dream of becoming
a hero but just as he was getting used
to his new quirk and his new life he was
contacted by all for one all for one
ordered aoyama to get into ua because he
had heard a rumor that almight would
start teaching there after that aoyama
was ordered to report to all for one
when class 1a would be isolated which
was at the usj and later he was asked to
leak the location of the training camp
most recently upon deku's return to ua
aoyama was ordered to lure deku out and
isolate him presumably so that over one
could ambush him and steal one for all
but at that point aoyama simply couldn't
go along with it anymore the letter that
deku left all of his classmates before
leaving the ua in the previous arc seems
to have had a massive emotional impact
on aoyama when he learned that deku was
also born quirkless just like him aoyama
fell into despair here was someone else
who had been born with the same issue as
him and yet deku became a true hero
despite all his hardships while aoyama
allowed himself to become a puppet for
the villains distraught and desperate
aoyama in the present fires off a naval
laser beam at deku and i'll be honest i
was not expecting him to just try to
snipe deku at this moment so that was a
little crazy but toru jumps in between
deku and laser and she uses her body's
unique ability to warp light in order to
shift the trajectory of the laser away
from deku as you guys will recall from
my previous videos about the trader
reveal i said that the class 1a students
would likely react very differently to
the traitor deku being deku will
definitely feel sympathy for aoyama and
he will try to save him and redeem him
but others will be far more angry and
far slower to forgive toru appears to be
one of those people because she can't
believe that aoyama could sit in the
same classroom as the other class 1a
students and act like everything was
normal and meanwhile he was putting all
of them at risk the entire time many in
class 1a could have died because of
aoyama's actions not to mention the
heroes and the students from other
classes who could have been killed by
the villains on top of that beyond the
ua itself japan has been thrown into
chaos and many people really have died
because of all for one and the villains
and all the while aoyama has been
supporting these same villains with his
information leaks we then finally get a
partial face reveal for toru as she
begins to shed tears over this whole
heartbreaking situation and from what we
can tell she looks like a normal cute
mha girl i feel like a lot of people are
already simping for toto just from the
partial face reveal but not me i am too
sophisticated for that and also i
already sprained my simping muscles with
all the simping i did for midoko lady
nagant and stars and stripes anyway as
toru continues to lash out at aoyama for
living in the same dorms as them and
just hanging out with all of them and
smiling with them while putting them all
at risk aoyama's parents try to jump in
and defend their son but then deku uses
that opportunity to tie up and restrain
all three aoyamas using black whip deku
tells aoyama to stop this already now
that toto has exposed him he doesn't
have to hurt anyone else we then see
both aoyama and deku crying and it is a
pretty heartbreaking scene the chapter
then jumps to some time later when
aoyama and his parents have already been
brought into the ua building for
interrogations with all might nezu
tsukauchi and the other teachers in
attendance alyam and his parents have
been tied down to their chairs and are
being questioned it seems that aoyama
first received his quirk around 10 years
ago and it doesn't appear that his quirk
was armed with the same self-destruction
mechanism as lady naganskwerk was so it
looks like they are safe to proceed with
the interrogation nezu tries to tell the
other class 1a students to step away for
a while presumably because this
situation is way too personal for them
but the students refuse we see a bunch
of them looking completely shaken by the
revelation that aoyama is the traitor
and mina is straight up crying kirishima
can't accept what's happening and he
screams at aoyama to tell them that it
isn't true but aoyama just sits quietly
in his chair tears still flowing from
his eyes tsukauchi is trying to learn as
much information about all from what is
possible from the aoyamas but yuga's dad
insists that they don't know anything
useful all they know is that they were
forced to carry out his orders and if
they refused or tried to lie to over one
in any way they would be killed all for
one even went through the trouble of
showing corpses of other people who
defied him to the aoyamas so that they
wouldn't doubt for a second that he is
capable of killing them if they went to
the police or tried to disobey or
deceive all for one he would know right
away and he would dispose of them and i
mean since we know that over one has
access to countless quirks and since he
has many people secretly working for him
i don't doubt that the aoyamus had every
reason to fear him even if they tried
telling the police some of the policemen
might have been working for all for one
or he might have some quirk that keeps
track of all of them so disobeying him
really could be risking death that said
aoyama proceeds to take full
responsibility for his actions and he
says that he is indeed rotten to his
core he says this because he was able to
act like everything was okay and pretend
to be just one of the students and yet
all the while he was putting all of them
in direct and serious danger after
learning that deku had also been born
quirkless and yet he still remained true
to his dream of becoming a hero despite
all the hardship aoyama became even more
certain that he was indeed a filthy
villain he was not brave strong or
morally upright like deku because deku
would never have put other people at
risk by doing what aoyama had done no
matter how much all for one tried to
threaten him and that in aoma's opinion
is the difference between a true hero
like deku and a rotten villain like him
but as i said before deku is deku so
naturally he's going to try to save
aoyama and offer him a path to
redemption deku says that if aoyama had
really been a villain he wouldn't have
gone out of his way to help tokoyami and
bakugo at the training camp and he
wouldn't have left that message with the
cheese a message that was clearly a cry
for help although deku didn't realize it
at the time deku also says that the
reason why aoyama is crying now is not
because he failed to carry out over
one's orders but because he truly
regrets being the traitor essentially
deku is saying that aoyama is not a bad
guy and that he still has time to do the
right thing just as lady nagant had done
in the end deku says that aoyama
shouldn't be labeled a villain for the
rest of his life just because he made
some mistakes in his past and he then
proceeds to hold out his hand to aoyama
the chapter ends with a crying deku
telling a sobbing aoyama that he can
still become a hero i mean this is all
pretty predictable behavior by deku and
this could turn out to be beneficial in
the long run if aoyama can be used to
trick all for one in some way however
since over one likely has other agents
within the ua grounds already it's
possible that he already knows that the
aoyamas have been exposed and if over
one knows that the traitor has been
compromised then the heroes won't be
able to use the traitor to their
advantage the thing that worries me is
that i can totally see deku doing the
same thing with shigeraki holding on his
hand to tenko shimura in an attempt to
save and redeem him but shigaraki is way
further gone than aoyama and sparing
shigaraki because he wants to save tenko
could cost deku dearly i've mentioned
this several times before but deku's
desire to save everyone even the most
ruthless villains is deku's greatest
weakness in battle since he is the main
protagonist i don't think that the
mistake of potentially going easy on
chikaraki in the future will cost him
his own life but it could cost someone
else their life such as for example all
might i could see deku hesitating in the
final battle against shigaraki because
he thinks he can still reach tenko and
then shigaraki using that moment of
hesitation to attack i can also see all
might sacrificing his own life in that
moment in order to protect deku but
we'll have to see how it all goes down
how do you guys think that this traitor
plot point will ultimately end will
aoyama try to help the heroes against
all for one and will it even matter or
does all format already know that the
traitor has been exposed does all for
one have any other traitors within the
ua grounds already and do you think that
the other students and teachers will
ever be willing to forgive aoyama like
deku seems to be willing to finally what
did you think about todu's partial face
reveal after all this time was it what
you were expecting and do you think that
we will ever get a full face reveal
don't forget to leave your thoughts down
in the comments below if you guys
enjoyed this boku no hero video and you
want to see more in the future just
leave a quick like it only takes a
second but it helps with the youtube
algorithm and if you're new to the
channel or maybe you watch our videos
regularly but you just haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet do me a quick
favor and make this the video do you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on twitter and instagram
at anime uproar i want to give a quick
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons for making videos like this one
possible special thanks to alpha sigma
this man is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord to ego himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrada algital
pate heffa the red-haired fox hinokamine
water the toasted chi corey mcgowan the
spike lonely dakar dylan isidor spidey
life tinel tungsten tarkis big buddhist
jeremy cummins and che whitley finally
thank you also to all of our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers on hell crews very
gucci alicia octor bonnie parks joanne
garcia fat boy games kaido might be a
duck jessica rabbit jeremy phillips
alivania and temple if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to you consider supporting us on
patreon even a single dollar will give
you access to our patron exclusive
discord and your name will appear in our
videos along with these legendary people
as always thank you guys so much for
watching and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you